und darüber vorerst sein abitur zu
machen hast du noch sechs stufen vor dir
also springt nicht an
ich liebe dieses format hey was geht ab
und jetzt willkommen beim neuen
video-botschaft wird sicherlich gut
ungefähr vor einer woche kam mir mein
video wo ich einfach mal ein bisschen
mir eure zeugnis angeguckt habe ihr
wisst ja alle meinen traumjob ist
absolut lehrer zu werden ich finde
schule bombastisch und dem ein oder
anderen kleinen tipp mit auf den weg zu
geben
ja das mache ich natürlich sehr gerne
nicht spaß also ich muss sagen ich
respektiere das auf jeden fall und finde
das echt wichtig dass es viele lehrer
gibt nur wie man auf die idee kommen
nachdem man zwölf oder 13 jahre in der
schule war noch weiterhin dahin zu gehen
das weiß ich nicht egal ihr habt mir vor
allem gestern noch mal richtig richtig
viele zeugnis von euch geschickt und ich
habe mir natürlich wieder eine menge
rausgesucht ich weiß der police coolen
ich finde auch richtig cool so dumm wie
sich das anhört aber er hat einfach nur
14 euro gekostet
da habe ich zugeschlagen also ich habe
eine menge zeug ist von euch rausgesucht
wir schauen uns jetzt gleich zusammen
und mal sehen was ich so dazu sagen kann
der letzte teil ist auf jeden fall echt
gut angekommen also wenn ihr das öfter
wollt dann lasst genau jetzt den daumen
nach oben da dann sehe ich das ja ich
sag mal so bei 8006 gibt's den nächsten
part ich will gar nicht lang aber wir
fangen an ich glaube der beste schritt
aus dem letzten part war ungefähr so 1,3
ich bin mal gespannt aber dass diesmal
toppen können so fangen wir mit den
etwas jüngeren an
wir haben hier einmal die celina und
celina hat mir einmal celina ist jetzt
in der siebten klasse
sie hat mir einmal ihr zeugnis aus der
vierten klasse geschickt und einmal ihr
zeugnis aus der ach so sexy meint aber
irgendwie das jetzt glaub ich in der
siebten klasse ist gefangen einfach mal
an mit dem zeugnis aus der vierten
klasse hier war selina echt noch gut
ich habe schon so viel waren celina ist
immer noch gut also wir haben jetzt in
der vierten klasse religion 2 das finde
ich so ein fragwürdiges fach wenn ich
meine das ist einfach da kannst du sagen
was du willst und der lehrer kann nicht
sagen das ist falsch das ist richtig
natürlich wenn es jetzt darum geht wann
wer wo geboren ist dann kann man das
schon was falsches sagen aber an sich
man kann auch total unterschiedliche an
das ist eine total viele
interpretationen wie man jetzt das
religiös wahrnimmt haben und da kann der
lehrer nicht sagen ja das stimmt nicht
also sagt was ihr wollt und zack habt
ihr eine gute note es sei denn der
lehrer den lehrerinnen akzeptiert nur
die eigene meinung aber vertraut ist ist
wirklich wichtig mündlich gut zu sein
weil das ist so schade weil schriftlich
extrem gut seid mündlich aber nicht
traut was zu sagen dann haben wir sofort
eine schlechtere note vor allem wenn es
dann auch wirklich darauf ankommt so
hofft der 19 11 10 12 klasse okay das
war schon wieder zu viel aber deutsch 3
hatte zwei sachunterricht zwei sports
war bildende kunst auf zwei wir haben
einen durchschnitt von ungefähr 2,2 oder
2,3 voll okay also ich denke mal die
zerlina ist dann aufs gymnasium gegangen
und wir haben jetzt das
halbjahreszeugnis aus der sechsten
klasse verhalten gut mitarbeit befrieden
evangelische religion 35 selina was
machst du denn erdkunde vier englisch 5
französisch hier matte vier
naturwissenschaften drei musik zwei
werken habe ich jetzt mittlerweile
rausbekommen das ist sowas wie kunst auf
zwei und sport befriedigen
celina war ein tag im staat das ist
natürlich voll in ordnung wenn man jetzt
mal schaun an der vierten klasse matte
zwei deutsch gut 3 und jetzt sind wir in
deutsch bei einer 5 in englisch auch bei
einer 5 ich fühle mich in diesem video
ist echt wir sind lehrer also zwischen
der vierten klasse es ist natürlich in
jedem bundesland anders manchmal ist die
sechste klasse auch noch grundschule
aber ich glaube so den sprung von der
grundschule auf die weiterführende
schule
das ist eigentlich noch mal einen niveau
steigerung also selina ist sagt ihr da
nur mal wahrscheinlich auch aber du
musst da was machen weil ich meinen wir
haben jetzt bestimmt schon durchschnitt
von 34
über 50 habe keinen bock das immer
auszurechnen und darüber vorerst sein
abitur zu machen hast du noch sechs
stufen vor dir also springt nicht an
ich liebe dieses format so leute wir
machen weiter und springen jetzt sofort
ich würde sagen in die elfte oder
zwölfte klasse ist auf jeden fall ein
oberstufen zeugnis worauf abitur gemacht
wird wie man hier sehen kann hier werden
schon punkte verteilt keine noten mehr
also man kann auch eine zwei minus 0 2 +
0 3 - haben für die personen in physik
mit 2 also elf punkte ist nur zwei
mathematik einfach nur 115 punkt ist es
sehr gut das ist echt krass vor allem
bei den mathe dass man in der oberstufe
hat habe ich nicht geschafft also
erdkunde 1 deutsch wieder mit zwei
englischen 2+ geschichte mit zwei
philosophie 2 plus da hatte ich eine
eins minus politik 2 - chemie 2 und
sport1 - das müsste auf jeden fall noch
ein einschnitt sein also wirklich noch
weiter so krasses zeugnis ich war
schlecht also willkommen zum nächsten
zeugnis und das hat mir die liebe ich
weiß gar nicht mehr es war auf jeden
fall mädchen und zwar geht sehen die
elfte klasse und da dachte ich wirklich
euro was hast du denn angestellt ihr
seht dass hier wahrscheinlich geschieht
öfter mal endpunkt b das heißt einfach
nicht bewertbar das liegt am meisten hat
einfach daran weil die person zu wenig
in den unterrichtsstunden da war und ich
sag mal wenn man von 50 stunden nur zehn
da war dann kann der lehrer ein jahr
schlecht bewerten wofür sich nicht
bewertbar mathe auch nicht bewertbar
kunst ist es eine 3 deutsch deutsch 5+
englisch 5 geschichte nicht bewertbar
religion auch nicht bewertbar politik
biologie 5 - seminarfach 3 - sport nicht
bewertbar also sie hat mir dazu
geschrieben dass irgendeine krankheit
hat und deswegen nicht so oft in die
schule gehen kann ist natürlich echt
schade vor allem jetzt schon in der
elften klasse ist wo es wirklich leid
mal schon drauf ankommen ich meine das
zählte schon wird ein abschluss also
erst muss ich sagen das ist echt das
schlechteste zeugnis von allen dass mir
zugeschickt wurde
aber ich wünsche dir gute besserung
hoffentlich wirst du schnell wieder fit
und kann sagen dass du es doch kannst da
man sich ja immerhin 13 schnitt
ausrechnen würde die besetzung ist
natürlich denke ich mal nicht
erfolgreich diesem fall das ist auf
jeden fall zwischen 4,0 und
aber nächstes jahr wird besser ich glaub
an dich und schickt mir dann einfach
seinen zwerg ist vom nächsten jahres
besser aussieht so wird das nicht so
zeigen es habe ich mich auch sehr
gefreut weil ich habe wirklich vorher
kennt ja wahrscheinlich alle die
waldorfschule hat man jetzt ziemlich
viele vorurteile darüber die können nur
den namen tanzen oder irgendwelche
mandalas ausmalen also ich hab mich mal
intensiv mit einer waldorfschülerin
unterhalten und das stimmt nicht die
lern zweiten damen zu tanzen
aber sie lernen auch ganz normale sachen
die mathe englisch und so weiter
der unterschied ist dann zum beispiel
nur das zeugnis und zwar gibt es da
nicht ein zeugnis versteht befriedigend
oder ausreichend oder gut wir kriegen
einfach aber so ein text ausformuliert
und da steht dann halt drin wie sie so
im schuljahr war deswegen die jetzt
dieses zeugnis da sieht man einfach nur
text ich habe mir jetzt einfach mal das
fach sport ausgesucht und da stand drin
zu beginn des schuljahres beschäftigen
sich die schüler mit dem erarbeiten des
kompressors zensiert also der name ist
zensiert wir nennen sie jetzt einfach
mal mit witz und vielen ideen schritt
chantal hier bei uns wir im unterricht
begegnete man ihr freundlich und
motiviert sie stellte sich den
unterschiedlichen anforderungen tauchte
in längere übungsphase nein das steht da
ich kann hat mich riesen hübschen
abzublasen
das heißt übungsphasen flugphasen ein
verbesserte einzelnen technische
ausführung mit dem ball und war somit
gut in der lage ihre sportliche
grundlage zu verbessern besonders die
leichtathletischen elemente waren für
chantal mit leichtigkeit zu nehmen zu
nehmen einzelne korrekturen umzusetzen
und ein gutes resultat zu erzielen wie
beim matten weitsprung chantal du
beherrschst bereicherung da bin ich echt
stolz auf dich also leute so kann ein
waldorfschulen zeugnis aussehen also ich
muss mich mal überein so willkommen zum
nächsten zeugnis und das kommt von
jasmin das war mit das beste zeugnis
geschickt bekommen habe und zwar geht
sie in die siebte klasse wir haben ihren
religionen eins im deutschen zwei
englisch auch zwei geschichte 1
geografie einst mathematik und physik
chemie 1 musiker sting 1 bildende
schätzung eines zeigt diese blamable 1 1
1 1 1
streber als jasmin grenzt da wirklich
fast an 1,0 nur mit den sprach und es
noch nicht ganz so eine 2 ist ja echt
jasmina musst du dich noch mal viel spaß
also das dürfte so mindestens 1,1 seien
wir nicht so 1,05 also jasmin macht
weiter so nur du darfst natürlich auch
nicht zu viel lernen macht auch viel mit
freunden gehe raus
vergiss nicht die schönen dinge am leben
ich meine das sieht ja bis jetzt ganz
gut da in die kommentare könnt ihr mich
so als lehrer vorstellen ich glaube ich
da gar nicht so schlecht so dann kommen
wir zum letzten zeugnis leute und das
kommt von niklas niklas geht in die
zehnte stufe und war 18 stunden nicht da
davon entschuldigt keine stimmen niklas
super bei mir bloß sich mit dem
schmelzen an deutsch vier englisch für
latein vier musik drei
sozialwissenschaft drei
erziehungswissenschaft reinmache 2 für
sechs jahren gut chemie 1 rallye 2 sport
sehr gut das sieht ungefähr so aus wie
bei mir
obwohl mir das mit für sich entschieden
einst überhaupt nicht jan niklas sollte
ungefähr so bei 2,4 und 2,5 liegen würde
ich jetzt mal tippen vielleicht auf 2,6
1 englisch hat damit erfolg teilgenommen
fertigungs fachmann kann in der zehnten
klasse wenn man auch im gymnasium ist
irgendwie so eine vertiefung wählen in
welchem fach man halt noch nicht so gut
ist dann wird es halt ein bisschen
vertieft bringt eigentlich überhaupt
nichts aber man muss halt hingehen dein
englisch und latein solltest du
vielleicht ein bisschen aufpassen latein
ist jetzt nach der zehnten
wahrscheinlich ewig wollte dann eine
platinum hausherr zum glück wird
ich kenne mich noch so gut aus aber das
wird schon leute ich würde sagen das
war's mit dem video mir macht diese
videos kultur spaß schickt mir einfach
mehr zeugnis sein darüber instagram oder
an meine mail alex email web de zu am
besten aber instagram daher sich einfach
alex wie wir sehen uns dann die tage
wieder ich muss jetzt ungelogen auch
weiter lernen schule hat auch wieder
angefangen glaube ich bei den meisten
also leute lassen doch noch um dafür
nächsten part wir sehen uns haut rein